let's say that you have a car that right
now is worth about ten thousand dollars
and you don't have ten thousand dollars
as a cushion if by chance your car were
to get totaled or if it were to get
stolen or something were to happen it
you don't have an extra ten thousand
dollars to then buy another car just
like it so one option you have to try to
transfer some of that risk is to buy car
insurance and this video is about all
forms of insurance but I'll just use
that as an example to just help think
about how Insurance works so what's
going to happen in that situation is
that you would likely go to an insurance
agent and he's like I would like to
insure my car in case it gets stolen in
case it gets totaled in case something
bad happens to it and I have to pay a
lot of money for that and so then the
agent they might work for an insurance
company or they might be able to get you
quotes from many different insurance
companies but they'll come back to you
and say okay if you pay two hundred
dollars a year and I'm making up these
numbers these aren't necessarily the
types of numbers that you will see when
you when you go to an insurance agent
but if you pay 200 a year
um we got you covered if anything were
to happen we will cover the cost of the
car you're like okay I do I can pay 200
a year and I'm willing to pay 200 a year
because I don't have ten thousand
dollars if something bad were to happen
so I agree to do that now the question
you might have is well how does the
insurance company make money here well
they have a whole bunch of people
looking at the statistics of it all
statisticians they're usually called
actuaries when they're at an insurance
company and they look at the probability
of something like that happening so
let's say they decide that there's a one
percent chance in a given year that they
are going to have to pay out ten
thousand dollars now if it was just one
person and in that if you're the only
person they insured and in that year you
paid 200 but they had to pay out ten
thousand that's not that good of a
business at least for that year uh they
they would have obviously lost a lot of
money but the way the insurance
companies work through it is that
they're actually insuring millions of
people and they're working on
percentages so for example if across
millions of people all of them are
paying two hundred dollars and there's a
one percent chance of having to pay out
ten thousand dollars well that means on
average one percent of ten thousand is a
hundred dollars on average they're going
to be paying out about a hundred dollars
per insured person who's just like that
and if they're getting two hundred
dollars well then they're going to be on
average making about a hundred dollars
profit people are paying two hundred
dollars that's called the premium what
you pay the insurance company
and then their actual statistical cost
is a hundred dollars so that's how they
would actually make money now let's say
as one of these bad scenarios happens to
you your car gets stolen it gets totaled
in some way well then you would make a
claim to your insurance company usually
someone there would uh then investigate
the claim uh if you made a police report
they would take a look at that they
would interview you make sure that
you're not committing insurance fraud
which is like you know you made the card
disappear but it really didn't disappear
don't do that highly highly illegal you
will get into trouble for that but then
if it's a legitimate claim then they
will then uh make the payout to you so
think about insurance but also think
about you know how they are benefiting
and how you can benefit and also try to
shop around for different types of
insurance policies you'll often see some
pretty dramatic differences in the price
of the premium that's that 200 a year
that I just talked about